my favorite question to ask somebody who
I respect and I want to learn from is
please tell me why I suck it might seem
a little crazy it might seem a little
out there but here's why I do it
feedback is so important for you to grow
your business you don't know anywhere
close to everything you need to know to
get to where you want to be and you're
going to get a lot of negative feedback
you get a lot of criticism you get a lot
of people who might be in your family or
friends circle or people you went to
school with who tell you their advice
right lots of people give you
unsolicited advice that's not
necessarily that helpful right telling
me that I suck is not the actual answer
for people around you but when it's
somebody that you respect who actually
has information to give you what happens
is people are afraid of hurting your
feelings so the someone who you look up
to who might be able to give you the
information they would be afraid just
because it's normal human nature most
people will not be direct honest blunt
tell you the hard facts and the truth
because they're afraid of hurting your
feelings but when you lead with tell me
why I suck here's what happened going to
share their one idea that's the safest
that's the simplest that's the easiest
that's the least likely to hurt your
feelings if you lead with tell me why I
suck then tell me why is like the worst
thing you've ever seen what they're
gonna do is say well it doesn't suck but
here's the three things I would do to
fix it you get a lot more truth you get
a lot more honesty because you led with
tell me why I suck knee motivation went
to top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Nina Carmichael and we made these videos
it's because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
that Push by surround yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best my husband Evan Carmichael and
our take on his top 10 rules for Success
enjoy
remember doing a keynote
um at a YouTube event
and I shared this strategy and and that
was the main theme for the ending and
they they filmed it and the MC came up
and said what did you learn from heaven
today
and they all said we suck
which as a standalone doesn't really fit
the believe Vibe of what I'm usually
going for but it was funny and they got
the message across because when I'm at
an event like that with YouTube
there are a handful of people that I
would listen to for advice right
as you get higher and higher and better
and better at something
you don't listen to everybody's opinion
anymore now if it's something like who I
should profile next or some themes or
content definitely open for its specific
strategies on YouTube you're going to
start looking at people who have
actually done it right as you get better
at something there's fewer people can
teach you so it's a handful of people
who I like to collaborate with and seek
their feedback and counsel and that's
what I always say every time I'm at one
of those events I'll find those people
like five people I can count on my hand
I would go hey man tell me why I suck
like you mind spending eight minutes
looking at my channel again and just
tell me why it sucks since like the
worst thing you've ever seen
and I'll say it exactly like that
and again the response is always well
dude like come on you don't suck you
have three unsubscribers it's great
but you know what here's what I would do
one two three
you're given permission to people to be
honest
you
recognize that it's out of love some
people will give you a lot of negative
comments not out of love
right they'll tell you that you suck and
all the things that are wrong and who
are you to do something like this and
what makes you think that you're good
enough to do this you don't have the
education and family and connections and
resources and money and smarts and
you're too ugly too right all of these
things that people throw at us but they
haven't done the thing that we we're
trying to do right if somebody hasn't
done the thing
that you want to do
their advice is not very meaningful if
anything you should probably do the
opposite because they don't know what
they're talking about and yet we listen
to these people right we we often listen
to the people who are closest to us
because they're in our proximity
but if they haven't done the thing
you know just because you went to high
school with them doesn't mean that their
opinion means something on the thing
that you're trying to do
chances are they took their shot at one
point and they didn't hit it and now
other people around them can't have
success either it happens a lot of times
so their advice is meaningless but when
you find the person and you seek out
people
who have done the thing that you want to
do
you have to give them permission to be
100 honest with you rule number two
think big Act small the secret to
getting everything that you want out of
life is to think big and act small think
big have a huge Dream create a vision
for yourself that excites you that you
want to make happen and then act small
don't let the big dream be so big that
it becomes so scary and you never start
find the smallest possible way to just
get started think big act small
otherwise your dreams will stay exactly
that I recently had a guy pop into my
Instagram live who was a fitness Coach
and he's he's building his success up
and doing one-on-one training and
fitness and helping people get results
and he said Evan how do I go bigger how
do I build my brand how do I get people
to know me outside of just my my pocket
my community
well you have to create content you got
to be a thought leader you got to be an
expert I got to see you doing what
you're doing how often are you making
videos
I said well I don't know making them
once a week
okay great dude how often do you go to
the gym how often do you work out how
often do you care about your nutrition
I said well every day like you have to
take this same approach to your business
to making content to being a thought
leader said are you in shape and at the
time he's shirtless and then he said
yeah I'm in shape and he he pans down
and you see his abs and then back to his
face he's got the smile on his face like
I love it man
you've put that into your daily routine
you're working out and eating right as
part of your daily routine he said yeah
but it's so hard to to go off and make
videos every day
what are your clients saying to you
about working out and eating properly
that it's so hard dude it's the same
excuses you've already figured this out
in one area of your life the problem is
you're not being consistent in the other
areas that if you want to blow up and be
a thought leader and get a lot of
traction attention and Views you need to
get good at the thing you don't become
great at anything doing it once a week
if you believe that you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something Michael
Jordan wasn't practicing basketball once
a week you just will never get great at
it you have all of this on top potential
all of this ability to go off and make a
huge impact but we never see it because
you're doing it once a week you just
will never get good at it you'll never
get good enough at the thing if you're
only doing it once a week so he says
what do I do right you put into your
routine
you already know how to do this you just
have done it for something else all of
you you've already been consistent on
something
now make this next business goal part of
your daily routine it's thinking big and
acting small most people think big and
have this big vision of where they could
go it's amazing I Believe in Your Vision
I love you I want to see you go off and
Crush that huge glow I think you can do
it
but then show me your calendar where you
take any action
because most people are spending too
much time just thinking thinking
thinking planning planning planning you
got to actually get going and doing it
daily consistent small action one video
from my friend who's running his gym now
one video is not going to do anything
one video one small Act is not going to
do anything it's the accumulation of the
daily videos that are coming out the
daily content the daily improvements
that's where you start to build momentum
the biggest thing that's missing for
most of your ideas is momentum because
you're thinking big but you're not
acting small rule number three trash
your idea great ideas flow through you
teach yourself train yourself that great
ideas are flowing through you that the
idea that you just came up with that
you've been thinking of that doesn't
make any sense is great is amazing and
is right for you because
quite often the ideas that come to you
don't make sense
are not practical someone like you
shouldn't do it
and whenever you're heading your heart
are misaligned
whenever your heart wants to do
something but your head tells you that
you can't do it
if you listen to your head you'll stay
small if you listen to the Practical
reasons why you can't do it then guess
what you won't do it you'll stay stuck
you'll stay small you'll stay crushed
for life knowing that you're capable of
more but never going after it so trust
that great things flow through you trust
that this thing that just came into your
mind if you're feeling bold ambitious
confidence in service that it's the
right thing for you and you need to go
and Chase it down rule number four be
I was in New Mexico
and I was doing on Super Bowl Sunday my
workshop and it was the smallest group
on our tour and we're talking about
morning routines and there was a woman
there and I asked her what what's the
most important part of your morning
routine and she said prayer I said so
you pray how often you pray every day
every day every day praise your praise
perfect how often do you feel
the prayer how often do you feel the
connection and how often are you just
saying the words
you said like half the time
great
other people might look to her and say
well look you do it every day even for
herself she might look in herself and
say great I did it every day as
Achievers we like to check the box right
you like to check the box I did it I did
it I did it I did it I did it I prayed I
watched the video I read the book I
brushed my teeth I whatever you have
your checklist and you did it right and
you feel great that you did it but if
you don't get the feeling
of courageousness and you just check the
box it doesn't count
so watching a video might be part of
your morning routine
great I I'm you know if it's mine I'm
honored to be a part of your journey but
somebody else is amazing do that too
but if you know that watching a video is
the thing that helps make you feel alive
bold confident
you know that there are some days that
watching a video actually makes you feel
that way and other days where it doesn't
and you know that watching the same
video over and over and over and over
every day will lose its impact super
quick right day one you're motivated day
two already you've lost like 80 of the
motivation that you got from day one day
three it's basically over you run it for
a month forget it like you've already
memorized the words that the words don't
mean anything to you anymore
so you have to have some variety
and if you're watching a video while
you're doing something else
this is the achiever's curse you're
watching the video while you're brushing
your teeth while you're taking the dogs
out while you're cleaning the sink while
you're making the bed you're distracted
you're doing something else you're
trying to multitask right here's what
happened to the achievers you still get
to check the box to say that you watch
the video
but because you weren't present for the
video guess what happens there was no
retention there was no feeling you don't
feel ready to take on the day you don't
feel the boldness to courageousness and
therefore you don't go and have a great
day even though you checked off
everything on your morning routine
that's what makes a difference
so if you get to the end of your morning
routine and you don't feel bold powerful
courageous ready to go for the day
there's one of two things that you have
to do one is you audit your morning
routine you say What's missing
you know like does this still work for
you anymore what's missing do I need to
add something in do I need to add an
espresso video in during the morning do
I need to add reading do I need to add
working out do I need to add writing my
goals down like what do you need to do
to add and tweak and experiment and see
if it makes you feel better or two
maybe you just need to do the routine
again but with more intention maybe you
did the whole routine while you were
distracted
maybe you did the whole routine while
you're thinking something else
so you don't get the feeling there's
nothing wrong with the routine the
routine is great
routine is perfect for you
but if you don't show up with intention
if you don't show up and be focused on
it you're not going to get the feeling
you could sit there and be in the chair
now think about going to classes going
to school you could sit there be in the
chair doesn't mean that you're going to
learn
you can sit there and watch your video
but if you brush your teeth and doing
eight other things
you're not going to get the feeling
this is the loving push forward that I
hope you accept
because everybody else is going to look
at you and see how much you're doing and
how perfect you are and how much
momentum you have and how many things
you're doing and they look up to you in
awe and you're an inspiration to them
and you should be because you are doing
amazing things
and at the same time you know it's
nothing compared to what you could do
but the difference between where you are
right now where you want to go is
actually not that big
the difference is just minor tweaks
between where you are right now where
you want to go for most of you it's just
minor tweaks
this is one of those minor tweaks
that if you could just stay consistent
on having a morning routine
and then inside of that consistency
doing the thing that makes you feel bold
powerful Unstoppable alive ready to
start the day not expecting to be
amazing when you wake up but then doing
the thing that brings that out of you
every single day your life
will change
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
number five
this is where intentional learning
really makes a difference
I can't tell you the number of events
that I've done
whether it's virtual or in person where
there's always q a at some point
so if you're going to an event
where you're signing up for for a zoom
call and the person who you want to
learn from is on that call what most
people do is they become passive
listeners
you're passively taking out your notepad
and you're taking notes you got your
phone and you're like taking notes on it
and like oh that's a good Insight that's
a good Insight but it's passive because
you are not
going in to the event with an outcome
your goal should be if you want to make
learning active if you want to actually
get the most from the experience and be
able to make the contacts and get your
questions answered you have to know what
the question is going to be
that you're gonna ask right so here's
what you should do
first off whoever Your Heroes mentors
guides are
you want to follow them on all the
platforms so they can go live I just
before this I was live on Instagram
and we had a whole bunch of people
asking questions
follow if you want to talk to me follow
me on Instagram
join my Discord Evan carmichael.biz get
in there we're having great
conversations but the people who are
your Heroes follow them on the platforms
where they might go live look at where
they might be speaking at an upcoming
event
and then when you go and attend that
event have a plan for your learning so
that it's not just passively going
through the exercise and activities that
they gave you that's all a bonus
if you're gonna go to some conference
and there's an activity sheet or
workbook to go through great that's all
a bonus you need to know going in
what do I want to learn if I got a
chance to ask this person one question
what would that question be
what's the outcome that I want from this
most people don't do that
and you get caught up in the hype and
the energy and the motivation of wow so
amazing woo
but then you still didn't get the answer
that you could have had if you're just
more intentional
so you show up and then when they do the
questions like okay we're going to q a
boom you're the first one there
you're the first one there you're not
you're not you might be nervous your
heart might be pounding out of your
chest like crazy but you're the first
one there
you're standing by the microphone you're
ready to go you got your hand up before
they even go to q a in the zoom chat
right like you are ready to go with your
question the one that you want and
answer to
and then you're gonna ask the person hey
here's what I'm struggling with here's
what I'm working on
tell me why I suck
and then you get the feedback
if you apply that strategy
and go after the top five to ten people
in your industry in your Niche who are
doing the thing you can get access to
them
and if you intentionally show up with
that one question that you want an
answer to
and then you end it with tell me why I
suck
you'll get their brutal honest feedback
and get the advice you actually need to
grow rule number six take immediate
action immediate action
immediate action to start building some
kind of momentum this is the problem
this is what we're missing what's the
first step that most of us take what's
the first step that you take what's the
first step
you most often immediately start to talk
yourself down does this does this relate
does this connect like as soon as you
get the idea immediately you're talking
yourself down forget about telling
friends family that that's a problem no
it's it's you it's your own mind that's
holding you back saying you can't do
things
after that what do we do we go into
planning mode plan plan plan plan plan
plan gonna research gonna make my
perfect plan I'm gonna gonna write out
all my questions for this interview
gonna you know research research
research and then and then what and then
what happens nothing
because you spend the first day planning
and you wake up tomorrow and you tell
yourself that you can't do it
so the first step is not planning
planning is important but it's not the
first step the first step is some kind
of immediate action this is where people
get cut UPS like what's the perfect
first step there is no perfect person
guys there's no perfect
anything you want to write a book
take out a your notepad your say
typewriter who uses a typewriter your
laptop your computer whatever
and just start writing take out take out
a piece of paper like this and just
start writing like if you're stuck in
the car and you come with a great idea
for what you should be doing for your
book pull over or if somebody else is
driving Nina drives while I while I film
these videos take out a piece of paper
and just start writing on this you may
think about this is nothing and you're
right but you know what something the
first step
momentum because your scribble notes
down here
that means everything
that's more progress than most people
ever make on their goals
because once you get started the next
step becomes so much easier it's the
first step that sucks the first step
that seems so giant
so don't worry about the perfect first
step just start building some immediate
momentum learn to take crappy first
steps
crappy first steps
crappy First Steps rule number seven
apply the two percent difference apply
the two percent difference the two
percent difference means as soon as you
get a goal in mind most things that we
want to do most people what we what we
do is we think of planning that's step
number one for most people it's planning
no don't plan your first step after you
come with an idea is to act planning is
important it's just not your first step
most people will plan their way to 100
right plan to how I'm going to
accomplish my goal and then they wake up
tomorrow they've lost the boldness they
lost the confidence and they say I'm not
going to do that I can't do that and
there's no momentum and then the dream
dies on the table the first step is
momentum the first step is action the
first step is figuring out the first two
percent that's it two percent don't plan
to 100 instead act on the first two
percent why is it so important because
when you're feeling bold when you're
feeling confident when you get that idea
it's flowing through you right you're in
that energy Zone you want to use that
energy to build momentum using that best
energy to go into planning and then you
wake up tomorrow in person you've lost
it all where if you use that energy into
action into momentum then tomorrow
you're going to wake up and see oh I've
already built some momentum it's easier
to keep the ball rolling the hardest
step is the first one so push build that
first step when you're feeling the
energy so as soon as you get your next
idea apply the two percent difference
your first step is to act rule number
eight help someone one of my instructors
at Toronto Dan salsa has lyme disease
also one of the guys on my marketing
team now has lyme disease but at the
time I knew nothing about I didn't know
what it was didn't know what it caused
didn't know how you got it didn't know
anything about Lyme disease but because
she has it
I started learning about Lyme disease I
set up a Google news alert that anytime
there was something about Lyme disease I
would get notified and I started sharing
things with her
that she hadn't seen before you know
started sharing that Avril Lavigne has
lyme disease and Shania Twain had Lyme
disease and they both took big breaks
from their singing career because of the
impact of Lyme disease if there's new
treatments or holistic healing or other
people talking about it then I would I
would share it with them and I would
also educate myself in that process to
the point now where she has opened up
her own Lyme disease holistic healing
practice and doesn't teach at my school
anymore she's left the school to go
launch his business and I'm so excited
for her it's great it's fantastic right
we're on a parallel path and now she's
jumped off and then have done her own
thing which is amazing now did I make
her go launch that business of course
not did I have a tiny little piece of
inspiration or hope maybe you know I'd
like to think so but when you can
help people accomplish their goals
it does two things
one it makes you feel good
you know how good it feels to help
somebody right we're all built to serve
where's the buck right there we're all
built to surf and makes you feel good to
know that you help somebody this is what
we all want to wake up and feel like
what we do matters is Meaningful you are
built to serve and so when you can get
out of your own selfish interests and go
help that person accomplish what they
want it feels good
I get more joy from doing that than than
a business transaction right I get more
joy from sending her something that
she's like oh my God I didn't know that
existed then how many views I got on my
video yesterday right it it feels weird
to know great we have three million
subscribers on my main Channel I don't
even know what that means it's hard to
even contemplate that it doesn't feel
like anything I can touch but knowing
that I helped one person with something
is the thing that gets me excited so it
feels good and the more you feel like
you're doing things that matter
at least to one person
it gives you the motivation energy to
just keep going because a lot of times
that's the thing that we struggle with
is we don't feel like what we do matters
it's not important then we lose
motivation then we stop we quit right so
you have to feel the connection to the
work you're doing rule number nine solve
a problem solve a problem
as you're talking to people who will be
using your product or your service who
will be engaging with your content as
you're talking to these people what is
the problem that they're facing
what is the struggle what is the
challenge that they're facing and then
help them accomplish it
if I apply it to myself and the YouTube
channels for context
one of the biggest challenges I think
people have is a very poor environment
you've got people in your life who keep
you where you are some people may be
telling you that you can't do things
that's the worst case scenario some
people might be cheering you on but they
can't guide you you're not inspired by
them the people around you are not
inspiring enough for you and that's why
you're stuck because the environment is
keeping you small
where if you are around higher Achievers
if you're around Tom bilyu and Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and these people
they would pull you to be better and so
that's the biggest problem that I see
the entrepreneurs that I love helping is
you know you're capable of more you've
got this big mission inside you you've
got the heart and the care and the
willingness to serve you've got
everything but you're not being pulled
forward by anybody
and so I want to try to create that
through content because you may not be
able to hang out with Tom bilio and Elon
musking up or Winfrey but every day on
YouTube you can hang out with Tom Elon
Musk and Oprah Winfrey from the content
that I'm going to make and create right
so that's the problem that I'm trying to
solve
and I get that because it was me who
struggled with it but also the people
that I see who I connect with who are
watching the videos they're leaving
feedback for me and I'm talking to them
and I realize you've got everything
you've got everything you you've got
everything
you're just missing that environment to
push you forward so that's a problem
that I solve what is the problem that
you solve when you can combine your
passions right step number one you
combine in your passions
step number two is we're talking to
customers people who are going to use
potentially what we can create and then
you're understanding what their problem
is and you solve it for them
that's how we start to build a
successful business
back to the entrepreneur success formula
if you get this formula if you apply it
it's simple it's basic and it's one of
the most powerful things you can ever do
and it's the one of the biggest reasons
why entrepreneurs don't win
despite having the heart and the care
and the service you have to combine the
thing that you love doing with all your
heart with something that brings value
to other people
bring those things together and you're
on to your next successful business
career rule number 10 the last one
before our very special
the great thing that you want out of
your life the the life you want to
create for yourself for your family for
the community for the world the life
that your family and you deserve is on
the other side of the things that you
are afraid to do and if you never jump
into it if you never address them if you
never do those things those great ideas
that you got inside your head that could
change the world if you never take them
on
you'll live your entire life knowing
that you you were capable of more
you played small you might have
convinced yourself of all the reasons
why you can't do it but really deep down
it's just fear and you played small and
we need to change that in this video
I just uh came back from doing an event
this weekend
was virtually uh where I spoke in front
of a couple thousand people
and just before going to speak
my niece was in the other room and she
asked me hey are you nervous you nervous
about this speech you're about to give I
didn't have any slides I was set to
speak for almost an hour
and I had one or two thoughts that I
wanted to make sure I got out and
I just wanted to jam with the audience
my favorite thing to do wasn't just to
give a prepared speech but to try to
bring as much value based off of the
people in the room and get their
questions and answer them and so she
said aren't you nervous doing that live
with no slides like are you nervous like
yeah I'm nervous
and I do scary things
if you look at your calendar for the
next month look at it look at look at
what you've got booked your next
calendar if there's nothing in there
that scares you I believe that you hate
your life
that just means that you're you're doing
the same thing over and over and over
again right you're photocopying your
life over and over and over and over and
over and over every day is the same if
there's nothing in your calendar that
scares you everything is the same people
ask me all the time they message me and
say how do I remove the fear how do I
get rid of all the anxiety like well you
don't all the way
having too much anxiety sure but you
don't want a life with no stress with no
anxiety with no uh
with no fear that means you're
repeating the same day over and over
again you would hate that life you'd be
bored out of your mind you'd be bored
out of your mind so you don't want that
life
the key is we're not attacking it we're
not addressing it you're not doing
enough to to jump into the thing and so
you're just reliving the same fear in
your head of what could happen over and
over and over and over and over again
the path through fear is through
it's not to play small every time you
get scared of something and you don't do
it you're teaching yourself to have less
self-confidence
if something if a great idea comes to
you
maybe you get a good idea from this
video or or another video or a book or a
friend you get inspired a great idea
comes to you and it's a big idea and
it's going to require you to grow and be
a better version of you right
and then you don't do it you play small
you find some excuse some reason why you
can't do it
what you're doing every time that
happens what you're doing is you're
teaching yourself that you play small
you're teaching yourself to have less
confidence in yourself less belief in
yourself
that you're not capable you're teaching
yourself in these moments every time
that you're not capable of doing these
things
I'm somebody who can't do this that's
what that's even if you don't say it out
loud that's what you're teaching
yourself every time that you play small
and you don't do the thing
you need to start to flip it
you need to start to show yourself that
you do difficult things that you take on
challenges that you jump into the fear
whether it works out or not is not the
issue whether you get the result or not
is not the problem it's did you try did
you put your best effort in
I'm a big believer that you have a big
mission a big Vision a big thing that
you're trying to accomplish and it's
inspiring why do you do the work that
you do because you're trying to make the
world a better place that's what we as
entrepreneurs want to do that that
mission is inspiring it's amazing it
gets you up out of bed
but sometimes it's too big
sometimes you think well who am I to go
off and do that sometimes you think well
other people should do that who have
more money and more funding and more
skills and more knowledge and more
resources I can who am I I can't do that
and so on some days the big why is
actually too big when you're trying to
motivate yourself to get going and take
action the big why might be the greatest
thing of all time but sometimes it's too
big that's where you need the little why
big why and the little y when the Big Y
seems too big you use the little y
what's the little why the little Y is
the small daily little comments that you
get the little pieces of feedback that
you get for me the little why is people
who who read my book trying to find a
copy people who read my book and then
they message me for people who leave
comments on my YouTube channel like you
guys who comment down below we read them
for people who DM me on Instagram that's
a little why it's knowing that the work
that I do has an impact
because a one-off comment doesn't mean a
lot in the grand scheme of things but I
know that I hit one person however many
views this video gets the people who
comment are way less than a number of
views right that's always the case
and sometimes the views don't make sense
I mean the idea that I get a couple
hundred thousand views a day on my
YouTube channel doesn't make sense what
does that even mean I don't know but
seeing somebody comment to say this
video had a big impact on my life thanks
to this video I'm taking action in my
business today like that's that's deep
and meaningful that's the little one so
find the little y version in your
business you may not think that you're
capable of accomplishing some big thing
every day but knowing that you help one
person and give you the motivation to
get up and do it again tomorrow and
again tomorrow and again tomorrow Big Y
little y don't spend money until you're
making money teach yourself that at the
beginning of your Venture you are not
going to spend your money
until you're actually making money what
are you gonna do you're gonna invest
your heart your hustle your energy your
drive your motivation but you're not
investing your money until you're making
money people say well don't you need
money to make money like no you don't
need you don't need money to make money
you need your energy you need your
resourcefulness as soon as you focus on
resources as being the problem you've
lost and it's never a lack of resources
it's a lack of resourcefulness
it's you feeling that it's a lack of
resources that is the problem and that
prevents action that prevents Forward
Motion because if you hey if I only had
x amount of money then I would be able
to do this
there's always a way to start smaller
there's always today you could do
something today some small step today to
move one little step closer towards
achieving your goals and it's that
inaction due to a lack of resources or a
perceived lack of resources that
prevents people from actually
accomplishing their goals and reaching
their their mission that's what happens
so there's always a there's always a
smaller way to get started and to teach
yourself especially at the beginning
that you want to be more resourceful
that you don't want to spend your money
until you're making money so instead of
focusing on how you can spend money that
you don't have think about how can you
do something with what you do have
and to invest your heart your energy
your time your hustle your drive but not
your money until you're making money
so so how do you do it you know what is
what are some of the steps well step one
is you dream big but you act small
big act small there's there's the
Mission you've got is amazing that's
what's going to fuel
fuel you like every day you're waking up
and doing something small you've got
this big drive this big ambition it's
awesome and act small like today do
something
instead of waiting for venture capital
or somebody put you on or to co-sign you
just do something
dream big most of us never take control
of our self-talk you don't take control
of the thoughts that you have about
yourself when you're by yourself it
doesn't even matter as much what our
parents think what our friends think
what our husband our wife thinks it's
you you're the problem you think
negatively about yourself you are not
consistently feeling yourself with
thoughts with positivity with ambition
with Courage the default pattern is one
of mediocrity of one of I can't do this
one of lack of resourcefulness and so
that's what you live and it's possible
to change and in making that shift and
making that change you become an
entirely different person we talk about
how do you become the best version of
yourself how do you live your life how
do you how do you show up as that proud
version this is it it's taking control
of the automatic self-talk that you have
to yourself even if you don't actually
talk to yourself even if you're not
saying Evan you're an idiot right Evan
you can't do that even if you're not
saying those things out loud you're
feeling those things
it's at a subconscious level and this is
where you're playing small and they've
been limiting yourself I'm afraid a lot
and I used to let that fear dominate me
I used to let that fear prevent me from
doing the thing that I needed to do
whether it's making videos whether it's
speaking on stage whether it's
interviewing people I don't believe in
being Fearless I think if you're
Fearless it means that you are just
doing the things that are inside your
comfort zone you're photocopying your
life I think if you're Fearless you
actually hate your life because you're
just doing things that you know how to
do I think fear is a great thing
it's not being Fearless it's having the
fear and then showing up because of not
even despite of because of because
you're afraid then you have to go do the
thing because you're worried then you
have to go do the thing because you're
afraid of somebody's judgments and you
have to go do them just because just to
teach yourself that you do it so for me
speaking on stage doing interviews
making videos with the three that I
struggled with the most this is a guy
who's made 10 000 videos has spoken in
front of thousands of people I've done
interviews with some of the biggest
people on the planet I'm still afraid
every time
I'm still afraid every time
and I don't let that fear now stop me
from doing the thing I'm still you know
I had Tony Robbins on my channel uh and
I had him on three years or two years
before
but I'm still nervous to have him on my
heart's still beating like crazy I'm
still an emotional wreck the day of I'm
still not focused
on anything else I can't do any other
work I can't make any other videos
because I'm I'm stressed about the
interview going well I still worry about
these things it doesn't go away there's
just levels to this
and I still want to show up where old
Evan younger Evan used to
find a reason why I couldn't do it find
a reason why I couldn't show up live in
the fear and justify it as an actual
reason or excuse but deep down I'll
justify think about your reasons like
why can't you do this thing what are you
telling yourself that you can't do
really deep down it's just
[Music]
a deep down you're just afraid
right if you're actually honest with
yourself you're just afraid living in
regret sucks
imagine you are 95 years old you're
looking back on your life at this moment
on this day realizing that you could
have played bigger you could have done
more you had more potential you had an
opportunity in front of you you could
have done something and you didn't you
didn't because you were afraid you came
up with some some reason that you
actually believed that was really an
excuse you played small you didn't
accomplish your goals now you're 95
years old and it's over and you can't do
it you're not physically or mentally
able to actually do it
the more you can actually feel that
that today matters that you want to stop
living your life by other people's
opinions and stop living with the fear
of regret
stop having that thing hang over your
head that you could have done something
and you were too afraid to do it the
more you can actually feel that it can
push you to actually take an action
because otherwise you live the life that
every Everybody lives that most people
live most people regret their life most
people regret not the things that they
did but the things that they didn't do
regret the ideas that you had then you
saw somebody else make a ton of money
off of you regret the conversation that
you wanted to take but you are too
afraid to go introduce yourself like we
live in this
zone of regret already you can feel it
look back to things that happened last
year two years ago or five years ago
like you wish that you showed up a
certain way you wish that you had more
courage more boldness and you didn't do
it you didn't do it and the point isn't
to beat yourself up over that the point
is to use that as courage to go do
something today towards accomplishing
your goals I used to use the fear of
regret a lot when I was when I was
younger especially to get myself to take
action the biggest decision of all the
hardest decision of all was to when I
was 19 not take the 100K a year dream
job that I thought I wanted to go become
an entrepreneur make 300 bucks a month
own 30 of a company that was the hardest
thing ever and the thing that gave me
the courage to do it was the fear of
regret
and Jeff Bezos has a great uh regret
minimization framework he calls it where
basically he tries to project out to
being you know that old old old old old
man and living life with as few regrets
as possible so I asked myself what will
I regret more
well I regret more saying no to my dream
job
and making six figures and travel around
the world or will I regret more saying
no to this business
and just not knowing
and I thought you know what I can always
go get another job
it may not be the same job it may not be
the same company it may not be the same
opportunity may not be as much money it
may not be as much travel may not be
this perfect job but I could get another
similar job I felt like I could get
another similar job this business idea
this business opportunity I didn't know
that I would ever have this chance again
and so I said you know what even if the
most likely outcome is failure I didn't
think it was going to blow up I didn't
know that it was going to work out or
not even if the most likely scenario is
failure I still have to do it because I
don't want to live with regret and I
told myself I would rather know and fail
than not know the number one way to deal
with negative people in your life is
through empathy it's empathy it's not
it's not hating them back it's not
spreading negativity it's not reminding
yourself that you're better than them
it's it's empathy and it's not even just
feeling bad for them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
I default to assuming that people are
good this is a wild idea people are good
humans are good I've done the who
exercised the year one word exercise
helping people find the most important
core value with so many people and it's
always something positive
I believe that
99.999999999 of people are good there's
a tiny tiny tiny percentage of people
who enjoy killing people they maybe have
you know a few screws loose up here but
for the most part we're good everybody
has dreams everybody has Ambitions
everybody wants to serve everybody wants
to be in a better place than where they
are right now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and and it didn't work out
and because they're so in pain now they
don't want other people around them to
have success either
because if they took a shot and it
didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them
right it's not that the world is rigged
against him it's that they actually suck
and they don't want to admit that and
they don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain
and so they take it out and other people
they take it out on you they take it out
on me they take it out on on the world
they take it out on people right that's
what that's what people do when they're
in a lot of pain think about you think
about your experiences your life think
about when you've been in a lot of pain
when you've struggled really think about
this the last time that you were
struggling in a lot of pain did you then
show up as your best self in all
situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe insult somebody did you
maybe say something that you're not
proud of that you later would regret has
it has that ever happened to you so that
you're a bad person it's not that you're
a toxic person it's not that you're a
hater
you were just in a lot of pain and so
the people who are throwing shade at you
are in a lot of pain they're struggling
and just recognizing that just trying to
put yourself in their shoes and look at
their life and if you know them you can
actually look at their life and if you
don't know them you can assume things
about their life if somebody's coming to
leaving a negative comment on your
YouTube video the fact that that is the
highlight of their day speaks volumes
about them right if the best part of
your day is going to somebody's YouTube
channel leaving some nasty comment that
gets you feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in mention what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning the natural
reaction is to be defensive like well no
I'm not this and how could you call me
that
and we want the people around to support
us and cheer us on and tell us that
we're doing the right thing so the
natural
defense mechanism kicks in where we say
no I'm that's not that's not right but
if you take a breather you can take a
step back and you can just try to have
empathy try to put yourself in their
shoes try to see that they're in a lot
of pain what it does is removes The
Sting from the words it removes the
Venom from the words it doesn't get you
to react as emotionally it allows you to
show up more as your best self
it's it's one of the most valuable
things you can start to practice this is
one of the things that prevents people
from creating content from posting
videos from sharing their thoughts of
you've got a big mission a message your
story can change people's lives you your
story your story can change people's
lives it will change people's lives and
we're afraid to do it because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're gonna get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start sharing to start releasing to
start living your life the life that you
want not somebody else's version of it
there's an order to things this is
sequence to things part of the problem
with a lot of entrepreneurs is they're
just not doing the things in the right
order
trying to tackle that big mission from
the start
[Music]
doing all 30 things at the same time
and not making any money and not making
any momentum not making any progress and
ultimately not having the impact that
you want to have
so out of your 30 ideas all inside your
mission amazing which one is actually
going to start getting you paid
because when you can start making money
everything becomes better everything
becomes easier you can quit your job you
can pay your bills you can hire a team
you can have a bigger impact right if
you had a team of 10 people versus you
doing things part-time on the weekends
and evenings
it's going to have a much bigger impact
if you have you working full-time and a
team around you how do you get there
what's the one idea of the 30. catching
that pattern it's like oh it happened
again again again I wanted to go and do
this and I didn't do it again I had this
opportunity to talk to somebody and I
played small again I had this chance and
I didn't do it and you're gonna catch it
a day later a couple days later and
reflect back on it and realize okay I
should have done it next time I'm going
to try to have more awareness
step one is just the awareness game
because it's the problem is it's it's so
autopilot we play small by default
especially we've been doing it for
decades you play small by default so
it's so ingrained so natural so
autopilot that we have to slowly shift
out of autopilot Zone eventually what's
going to happen is you're gonna catch it
in less than a day you're gonna catch it
a couple hours later they're gonna catch
it an hour later they're gonna catch it
10 minutes later they're gonna catch it
five minutes later and then step number
two is you're gonna get to this magical
moment you're going to get to this
magical moment where it's about to
happen you've caught it you've caught
your small thinking you've caught your
scared thinking you've caught your
excuses thinking
in the actual moment that it's happening
this is a magical spot right now
because you're actually calling yourself
out on your own BS right now and what
you need to do is get enough courage to
actually take the action to Pivot
courses to instead of doing what you
historically normally would do on
autopilot now we're going to take the
other action the action where you're
proud of yourself the action that you
don't want to live and regret
that version of you showing up spend a
little time with yourself and and finish
the sentence I am what I am blank I am
blank what's the blank you are what if
you're just by yourself you have a
little space to breathe from your
environment you are what what are some
of the words that come up what are some
of the positive words what are some of
the negative words that show up if
you're being honest with yourself
there'll be hope with some positive ones
so
um for me it could be I'm someone who
believes I am
I am a great husband
I'm paying attention I am you know a
great father I am a great not owner what
do you do with dogs I don't know a great
thing you're still consider your kids
they're my kids yeah they're kids pet
kids all right you know I am a bit down
on the negative side like I am uh afraid
of disappointing people I am scared of
speaking on stages I'm worried that I'm
gonna ask bad interview questions like
what are the positive and negatives if
you feel in the I am okay just to get
awareness of yourself this starts to
uncover some of the subconscious
behavior that you're living on autopilot
right the subconscious is the autopilots
what you're doing by default the
conscious of what we want to take
control of to then turn into
subconscious to then make
the automatic the positive the ambitious
the Bold the courageous right
so start with I am what that does is
lead you to step two which allows you to
identify your trigger words so what are
the trigger words that you use
consistently as an excuse for you not to
do the thing so my three trigger words
are scary difficult or hard that when I
say scary difficult hard
those used to be the reasons why I
couldn't do something those used to be
the reasons why I would let myself off
the hook those used to be the things I
would tell myself oh I can't do this
because it's scary I can't do this
because it's difficult I won't show up
because it's hard and I would let myself
off the hook for those things that I
would say oh that's okay because it's
scary so I'm not going to do it and and
I would that would used to be my
identity you want to swim forever adopt
the mindset that you want to swim
forever most people if you're thinking
about swimming
you're swimming to reach the island
right if you're swimming on the ocean
the island is is some gold the island is
I want to hit a million subscribers I
want a million in revenue or whatever
some arbitrary goal
the goal isn't to hit the island
your intention shouldn't be to hit the
island it should be the swim you have to
love swimming you want to swim forever I
want to swim forever
every now and then you might need to
look back
you know and see how far you've come
see how far you swam every now and then
we need that
that mindset that that that
gratitude that perspective to say wow
I'm I'm so much further ahead Than I
Used to Be Right a big challenge with
Achievers is we don't feel like we've
done enough
especially High Achievers you don't feel
like you've done enough
and and that can often be a drive
forward but sometimes it's so
overwhelming that it actually puts you
in a negative state where where it
prevents growth so in those moments you
look back and see how far you swam like
wow I've come a long way compared to who
I used to be the the accomplishments the
belief systems the mindset the
relationships like the personal
development how much have you grown if
you actually think about it how much
have you grown in the past five years is
probably crazy if you're a fan of this
channel you're watching this video
you've grown a lot in the past five
years and every now and then when you're
feeling low you need that perspective
shift to look back and see how far
you've come but otherwise it's forward
growth more growth you want to swim
forever you don't want to hit the island
you want to swim forever
we've all experienced those moments
where you you hit a goal
and then and then what what do you feel
you feel a moment of Happiness of of
accomplishment and then like oh is that
is that all there is
and when I hit a million subscribers on
YouTube like that was a drive that was
the goal I want to hit a million
subscribers on YouTube
[Music]
I wanted to hit it I don't even remember
what the goal I wanted to hit it before
Gary
I wanted to hit a million subscribers
before garyvee and we did it
and they're like oh I'm still the same
person
somehow we feel that when we
accomplish something we're gonna feel
different we're going to be different
you're going to be a different person
when you hit that goal and it's it we
end up getting confused because it's not
even about the goal you become a
different person in the pursuit of the
goal
I've studied more successful people than
most people just in the nature of the
work that I do and there's a reason why
the number one rule for Success over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again is you have to love what
you do you have to love the process
successful people they love the process
they love the doing they love the actual
showing up every day
I'm sitting here at a
Nina's inside there can we see Nina's
inside at a at a TNT it's a Chinese
grocery store she's inside doing
shopping I'm sitting here in the car
making videos why because I like it I
like I like the process I like it's not
about how many subscribers I have on the
channel I like feeling like this matters
that you I'm so grateful that you're
thank you honestly thank you for
watching this video I'm so grateful that
you're here watching this video that I
could make something from my car that's
worthy of somebody else's attention
thank you
I love this we've done over 10 000
videos
why because I love it like if it's just
a strategy if you're just trying to
reach the island you drown
if you're just trying to reach the
island you drown you have to love
swimming
this is the mistake most entrepreneurs
make when they're first getting started
is you're just chasing an opportunity
but you don't actually love the process
this is a great
uh quote one of my favorite quotes of
all time it's an African saying that
beyond the mountain is more Mountains
and it's similar to the swimming analogy
what do you do when you get to the top
of the mountain there's another mountain
to climb you don't you don't ever want
to get to the top of the mountain think
about if you if you hit the top
you're gonna start to hate your life
because there's no growth because we
want more growth we want more learning
we want more progression if you felt
like you hit the top that's the fast
path down to depression beyond the
mountain is more Mountains the greatest
quote of all time at least one of them I
love that one I think a Ted Turner's
father whose goal was to be a
millionaire and then he hit the million
and
he killed himself
[Music]
because he thought you know he wasn't
happy with his life he wasn't happy with
his his process he wasn't happy with
doing every day but if he hit a million
dollars then everything's gonna change
then he's gonna be a different person he
hit his million and he was the same
person he wasn't happy so he killed
himself
so Ted Turner who's you know a
billionaire one of the wealthiest people
in the world decided I'm going to set a
goal so big that I'm not going to hit it
and that's the point of having a vision
you know a mission like something so big
Beyond yourself that you never hit it I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem that people don't believe in
themselves enough
I'm never going to do that it's not it's
not going to happen not in my lifetime
and yet I wake up every day trying to
make that happen in my lifetime
you have to want to swim forever tell
the people around you
so Nina Nina stepped out but uh Nina my
son my team my family I'll let them know
hey if I say scary difficult or hard I
want you to let me know
if I say to you in any conversation I
can't because it's scary or it's
difficult or it's hard I need you to
call me out on it because I'm not I'm I
still don't catch all of them
it's a lot more than it used to be and
I'm probably I don't know 90 95 of the
way there but there'll still be some
small percentage and having people hold
you accountable
is really important
Now the default thinking for them is
going to be what are you talking about
you you're always doing all of these
things you're always showing up you're
always doing scary difficult hard in in
my case
yeah but not like I could be
there's another level to this
and everything I want out of life my
mission my my vision my boldness is on
the other side my great life is on the
other side of even more scary difficult
than hard
I had to start living it and so I need
help in catching it
so you use yourself as step one as the
first part but then if you can as a
bonus bring in the accountability to the
other people in your life who can help
you catch it and you're not allowed to
get angry at them you're not allowed to
get frustrated with them if you say one
of your trigger words and they say you
just said it
You're Gonna Wanna Say now but it
doesn't count it doesn't mean it uh I
was thinking so stop letting yourself
off the hook
and said you say you're right I need to
go do the thing and the more you can
train that
Checker where he came up I'm doing the
thing trigger war came up I'm doing the
thing trigger work came up another thing
it's scary I'm doing it it's difficult
I'm doing it's hard I'm doing it just
because you start shifting your identity
you start changing your self-talk
now you start to become the person that
you're proud of you start to become the
person that you you say you want to be
you start to actually become the person
you've become the best version of you
inflict so much pain on yourself a
future regret that if you don't do this
thing how painful it's going to be for
you how you're going to regret it your
entire life that it forces you into
action to do the thing that will make
yourself proud that will build the life
you want that will help create the dream
that you know you're capable of doing
spend five percent of your time planning
strategizing thinking and 95 of your
time doing executing tactics I call it
the 595 rule five percent of your time
thinking planning strategizing and 95 of
your time actually doing this is where a
lot of entrepreneurs get held up because
we're dreamers we want to change the
world we've got this big mission this
big Vision we've got all these amazing
giant planes and it's so much fun to sit
and think and plan and watch videos and
draft up what our perfect company our
perfect life the perfect world's gonna
look like it's a ton of fun anytime you
get entrepreneurs together and you start
dreaming about the future but tell me
about where you want to go what you want
to build those are really fun easy
exercises for us we love staying there
the problem is none of that stuff
actually happens until you do something
right the perfect world you want to make
the perfect life you want to build none
of that happens until you actually start
doing it think about
working out is an example right you
could you could research all the
exercises you could think about the
beautiful life you're going to have when
you have your six-pack abs but nothing
counts until you actually start working
out until you start running and and
doing your push-ups and doing your
sit-ups and your squats and all of that
stuff five percent of your time should
be picking the plan strategizing the
plan and 95 of the time actually doing
don't want to be in the same spot a year
from today a month from today heck even
a week from today we don't want to stay
stuck you don't want to be in the same
spot you don't want to be having the
same thoughts to say I wish I could be
further ahead I should be doing
something else like to have the
frustration with yourself your life your
lack of momentum if you don't want to be
stuck in the same spot
one week one month one year from today
the difference is not going to be
different strategies that you come up
with you're you're super smart
you're a smart person and you're doing
this for the right reasons you've got
heart you want to serve
you want to make a difference you want
to feel like what you do matters
the only tweak you have to make
is switching the time you're spending
thinking and pondering and in fear and
strategizing and moving it
to just doing
to just executing to doing one more
so that's a challenge for today
look at your calendar for the rest of it
today for the rest of next week
5.95 five percent time planning thinking
strategizing and 95 of your time doing
that will make the difference the
biggest problem is a lack of belief my
biggest problem your biggest problem the
world's biggest problem is that we don't
believe in ourselves enough you could do
great things you could be the Michael
Jordan of something you are literally
the greatest in the world at something
but if you don't actually believe that
you are
then you won't be and people with far
less Talent far less resources and far
less heart than you will win because
they just took action so my biggest
limitation is still a lack of belief
it's still the thing that holds me back
I'm I believe in my ability to do what
I've already done but not to do the next
thing
it's a constant battle and a constant
reminder because you want to grow I want
to grow I want to keep learning I want
to keep getting better and so to get to
that next breakthrough I'm gonna have to
believe in myself to say I can do it
just yesterday I was on Instagram live
with Kevin O'Leary Mr Wonderful Shark
Tank was a super fun interview and the
hour before it
I was just uh totally useless I gave
myself an hour before to prepare to
research to think about what questions I
wanted to ask to think how I'm going to
introduce him when he comes on
I I don't have a connection to Kevin
Miller before yesterday I I've Had The
Good Fortune to meet tons of people and
connect with them but Kevin I haven't
done anything with over the how many
years have had my YouTube channel it's
crazy so I'm nervous
and in the back of my head is he's a
professional he's it's going to be great
he's not somebody who like yells at his
you know interviewers it's gonna be fine
but in my my heart I'm still I'm still
nervous I'm still worried I'm still uh
anxious that I'm gonna say the wrong
thing ask the wrong question uh not give
a great interview and you know it's over
in in seven minutes is my panic attack
taken over and so that hour before the
interview I was I was completely useless
um I I kind of went over at least 10
times how I was gonna introduce him and
some of my key questions that I was
going to ask him and then I just
basically wasted time I wasn't in the
right mindset to be able to go and do
anything else I couldn't even do
Instagram DMS or emails because I was
too distracted thinking about this thing
that was coming up
but what's the alternative
you know whenever you face those doubts
whenever you face those fears the
alternative is say no the alternative is
oh I I can't do it I'm I'm busy find
some excuse right Evan of 10 years ago
probably would have backed out of it
would have found some reason why I
couldn't have done it I'm busy uh you
know find something some find some
reason
I want to teach myself that I do scary
things that I do difficult things that I
lean into the thing if I don't believe
in myself enough then I have to go do
the thing to show myself that I believe
in myself you can say all day long I
believe in myself I believe in myself I
believe but if you don't do the thing
you won't believe in yourself
and so you do it scared you do it when
it's hard you do it when it's difficult
even if I go on the live and
just say the wrong thing to Kevin and
insult him or he leaves or something
happens the fact that I showed up with
with with a positive intention with the
goal to try to make this a great
interview is enough for me to Pat myself
on the back and say I did it now the
interview ended up going great at least
I thought I thought it went well we had
a good conversation we talked about his
new business I made a new connection you
know follows me on Instagram it was it
was a fun time and logically you might
be watching and thinking of well of
course it's gonna work out you've done
all these interviews and logically to
myself it's the same thing of course
it's gonna work out I've done all these
interviews and with harder people to
talk to than Kevin O'Leary
but in the moment when the superior
talking the logic isn't enough to get
you through it at least for me it's it's
the boom boom boom test that my heart's
beating boom boom boom boom boom I'm
nervous I'm scared I have to do it
that's how you start building confidence
belief self-respect by doing difficult
things number one is be surrounded by it
be surrounded by the things that make
you believe in yourself more this is so
critical because chances are the people
around you aren't encouraging you to be
more aren't pushing you saying you're
capable of so much more a lot of people
have either haters around them people
telling them that you're never gonna
make it be safe be practical go get this
safe job over here you can't go do that
or people who might
have empathy might have some kind of
understanding but they don't know how to
push you to do greater things and so you
have to be surrounded by the people who
make you feel like more as possible this
is so critical it's so important it's
why I make this YouTube channel I want
you to start your day with confidence
and belief so if this channel does it
for you great hey every day I'm making
videos if not on this channel they've
got lots of other channels also making
content but if it's not me then it's
somebody else if it's Dean's Channel or
Dean's books or Dean's podcast that
makes you feel bold confident a lie
powerful then then be surrounded by it
as much as possible have it as a part of
your regular schedule have it in your
environment look at my environment here
look at the people on the wall behind me
I walk into here and these people make
me believe in myself more from Steve
Jobs to AP giannini to my parents Howard
child's Kanye West these people make me
believe in myself more from from the
cell phone background that I have and I
load it up it says it says remember your
intention
remember your intention ah you can see
it hey you can see it it works remember
your intention as a reminder reminder
for myself my desktop background the
clothes that I wear right I feel like
I'm Batman going to work I feel like I'm
a superhero going to work to try to
change the world for the better every
time I put this on now that might seem
crazy to you that might seem stupid
childish ridiculous awesome go do you
but think about it from your office
environment to you know the screens on
your phone and computer to what you wear
it impacts your psychology it impacts
your self-confidence so you want to be
around it as much as possible physical
environment plus online environment for
the the music you listen to the podcast
the videos you're watching to every day
inject that belief into yourself step
number two is fix your morning routine
most people well most people don't have
a morning routine so most of America
doesn't have a morning routine but if
you're watching this video you probably
have some kind of morning routine most
people wake up like an accident you
probably wake up and have a morning
routine and so your friends and family
people who look at you they might even
be in awe of your morning routine and
say how how do you accomplish so much
and how you stick to that morning
routine you're the one that people are
going to for advice on morning routines
but your morning routine is likely still
broken
but the most important part of a morning
routine is it's not brushing your teeth
it's not uh you know meditation it's not
even watching one of these an espresso
videos as much as that breaks my heart
the thing that's most important in a
morning routine is do you get the
feeling of belief of Unstoppable
confidence of boldness when you finish
it
too many people are just checking the
boxes too many people are saying well
okay I'm gonna wake up I'm gonna brush
my teeth I'm gonna read a book I'm going
to work out I'm gonna X great check
check check check check perfect you
checked all the boxes you did it
but you don't feel bold
you don't have confidence you don't feel
the belief
why well one of two reasons one either
your morning routine is broken and you
actually have to inject something in you
have to actually watch that video or
make that call or do that meditation or
say that prayer or whatever the thing is
you have to add something into your
morning routine to get the confidence
or two your morning routine actually is
okay you're just not doing it with
intention so remember my cell phone
screen here right remember your
intention remember mine this is how do I
there we go remember your intention this
is a constant reminder for myself
to remember my intention
your morning routine
you might have all the right pieces to
it and maybe watching a video is the
thing that gets you feeling fired up and
ready to go and have that belief but if
you're watching the video while you're
doing something else if you're watching
a video while you're brushing your teeth
or while you're planning out your day or
while you're making your lunch or
something else and you've only got half
your brain on it and you're not actually
too focused on it then great check you
watch the video you can check it off
your morning list but you don't feel the
feeling and if you don't feel the
feeling if you don't feel bold powerful
Unstoppable confident coming out of your
morning routine then you need to
immediately fix your morning routine for
tomorrow it's one of the single greatest
things that you can do because if you
woke up and did the thing that made you
feel belief confidence boldness every
day if that's how you started your day
you actually felt that every day your
life is gonna look dramatically
different when you're from today I
guarantee fix your morning routine and
step number three is pass the boom boom
boom test and the boom boom boom test is
when your heart's beating boom boom boom
that's a sign to go that's a sign to do
that's a sign of your your beliefs in
yourself being questioned when I had
Kevin O'Leary coming up on my show boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom right
even having Dean on my show
I had Dean not too long ago on my show
and now I know Dean better we've hung
out in Puerto Rico he's been on a couple
times already we spent some time
together so uh he's he's a closer friend
than Kevin O'Leary who I didn't know
before now the last time I had Dion was
to promote his book but I couldn't bring
him in for more than a couple seconds
Instagram I bring him in and it would
crash and so should I bring him in and
they would crash again so and I tried
like four or five times to try to bring
him in and he's sitting there live and
it just keeps crashing and it felt so
terrible it's like all my my worst
nightmares come and chew right like it
didn't work out oh my gosh I feel so bad
I'm letting him down and letting my
audience Down live it just felt terrible
and so in the back of my head is oh my
gosh remember the last time I tried to
have Dean on the the Fiasco that
happened and so boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom I don't want it to happen
again this time but not letting the boom
boom boom this is just your fear talking
right it's just a lack of belief talking
it's a lack of belief that it's gonna go
well this time you can't let that hold
you back from actually doing the thing
and quite often what happens is you feel
the boom boom boom boom boom right it's
going like this
but then your brain will find some
reason why you can't do it your brain
will talk you down from doing the thing
you'll find a really logical smart
reason because you won't believe a
stupid reason a really smart reason why
you can't do the thing and so you don't
but really you're just afraid and so
this helps you catch it when you feel
the boom boom boom it's going like this
your heart's beating I'm scared and I'm
doing that thing I'm doing that thing
I'm going to reward myself for the
effort whether it ends up working out or
not because I do scary things and so do
you the fact that you look at your
calendar today tomorrow next week and
nothing excites you okay great what can
you shift and it may require a wholesale
change it may require you doing some
drastic thing but more likely you could
probably just do one small shift
like just start building momentum just
start doing one little thing every day
to start to train yourself to start to
just push the ball a little bit forward
because often we think we have to make
some giant change and the only answer is
to move to Mexico and then it never
happens because to move to Mexico takes
you however many you know months and
budget and all the stuff you get stuck
in plenty more instead of doing
what's a small step what's a small tweak
that you can make to today's calendar to
inject more energy into it with
something that you're going to love
doing that will give you more energy
that then now you have energy for other
things as well right some kind of
immediate momentum the fear for gret is
one of the most powerful tools at your
disposal to help you get into action
mode
let me explain what whatever you want to
do whatever your goals are your your
mission your mission your dreams
whatever you want to do
[Music]
right
over and over and over and over and over
again so therefore your dreams your
Ambitions your drive require you to do
things that are scary that are new that
are different that are pushing you
outside your comfort zone and our
natural reaction is we don't want to do
those things
right in theory we do when we feel bold
and confident we do when you watch a
video like this you get inspired and
motivated like yes I'm gonna go do it
and then when it comes time to actually
doing it you find a reason why you can't
do it
too tired I'll do it tomorrow there's
always some logical reason why you can't
do it meanwhile it's just fear
understand that under underneath your
excuses your reasons are just fear it's
just fear you're afraid of doing a thing
you're afraid of being judged you're
afraid of who will see it you're afraid
of who won't see it if nobody's saying
it you're just afraid you're afraid
and getting to your dreams require you
to step through that fear and the future
regret
fear of future regret is so powerful
because it can knock you out of the
immediate fear of doing the thing so let
me break it down
if you had to make a video You're gonna
make a video yeah I'm making a video
right now right if I was afraid of
making this video refer to make this
video I'm afraid of I'm gonna have the
wrong words I'm afraid that Nina is
going to judge me for the words that I'm
saying
I'm afraid that my dogs are not going to
be happy with me whatever you're afraid
of of what what that guy thinks for for
me with with my phone right you're
you're afraid all these things come
through our our head of what we're
afraid we're afraid of and by the way
Ian is very supportive as always we love
you Nina anyway you're afraid so if
you're afraid of making a video great
the fear the present fear is very real
it feels it feels big right let's call
it let's put it on a fear score the fear
of actually making that video is a 50
okay it's a score of 50. that's how much
afraid we are to do it
the fear of the regret of not doing it
in the moment it's not very big maybe
it's a one
right it's just a one it's a one
the the idea that okay I might regret
this one day whatever it's a one
but the problem is
50 is just for today that little fear of
oh it's a big fear but in the moment of
doing the one thing say it's a 50. it's
just today the regret compounds so it's
it's it's one today and it's one
tomorrow and it's one the next day it's
one the next day it's the one the next
day it actually ends up being a million
right it ends up being huge
the fear of inaction becomes huge but we
don't feel it on a day-to-day basis
because it's too small compared to the
present fear of doing the thing so what
you have to do
and this is the this is the hack to get
out of procrastination bless you Nina
this is the hack to get into action mode
this is the hack tool actually start
chasing your dreams down believe Nation
come on let's go is to make the fear so
big of regret that you're gonna miss out
that this video that you're about to
make today is going to be the video that
is life altering life-changing life
redefining for you
is one thing that you're about to do
greatest moment of your life
so you make that pain so big
now it becomes a million versus the 50.
right so then it's not as as scary to go
do the thing
because there's a bigger fear you're
basically inflicting a future pain so
big on you that the present pain doesn't
feel as big for too many of us there's
no deadline when's the deadline on your
dreams when's the deadline to make your
content what's the deadline to actually
execute things for most of us is no
deadline you don't have a deadline and
so because you don't have the deadline
you allow yourself to procrastinate and
to and to Tinker on to make things
perfect and to never release because
there's no deadline it doesn't matter
enough
when I'm making videos I have to make a
certain number of videos every week for
my channels and there's a deadline I
have to get them done today they have to
get done today because tomorrow I'm
doing something else and the next day
I'm doing something else and I'm not
touching my YouTube content again until
next Tuesday
so if I don't get it done today then my
team doesn't have content to go off and
create for the channels and then I'm
disappointing you
and it's been I don't know seven or
eight years since we haven't not since
we have not haven't not since we have
not uploaded a video on one of our
channels
years it's been years
of consistency and that's
how you start to build the machine
because there's a deadline because it
matters because it's important today
have a reminder system in your life
constantly what are the things because
you feeling it right now hopefully if
you're watching you're feeling it right
now you're feeling excited right now
you're gonna make a change right now and
then tomorrow you're going to fall back
to who you used to be so what what do
you need in your environment what do you
need in your habits and your daily
routines to remind you you need to
remind your system so it can become more
automatic that it doesn't rely on your
self-will and your discipline constantly
that it gets introduced to you
constantly whether that's
uh YouTube videos why hey espresso five
days a week every morning hey I'm here
let's go it's a new
at my let's Channel or Tony Robbins
Channel or or Oprah Winfrey's videos
like whoever or if his books or podcasts
if it's your physical environment if
it's uh morning intention like just
figure it out for yourself
and schedule it in
schedule in the reminders
schedule in the intentionality so that
this doesn't just become a one-off
moment but that it's a daily reminder
it's a daily consistency it's daily
momentum because you need that happiness
comes down to fulfillment versus
excitement when people ask me hey Evan
how do you how do you define happiness
is one of the most common questions I
get asked when I'm doing interviews and
podcasts and such what does happiness
look like to you well happiness
is fulfillment and excitement
because it's very interesting word so
let's break it down fulfillment is
feeling like what you do matters
you're happy when you feel like what you
do matters you're happy when you feel
like you wake up today and today is
going to matter this is what we all want
we all want to feel like what we're
going to do today is going to have an
impact on somebody else's life we are
all built to serve you want to feel
important to somebody else not just from
a ego perspective that oh I matter and
I'm important but in a way that you
contributed to somebody else's life
we're all connected we want to feel
connected we want to feel like this is
going to matter today that this video
that I make for you even though I'm here
just in the car by myself
Molina's actually Nina's back there
hello Nina even though I'm just here
filming by myself in the car I want to
feel like this video is touching
somebody it's touching you that you guys
are watching it and hopefully the
message here is going to be inspiring
and helpful to you in some way we all
want that that's fulfillment right if
you wake up too many days in a row and
you feel like today doesn't matter if
nobody cares if I show up nobody cares
if I do a good job or not nobody cares
that's a fast path to depression and
worst case suicide right that's where a
lot of people unfortunately are living
right now is they don't feel like they
matter they're not happy because there's
no fulfillment
they're not happy because they feel like
they don't matter to anybody
so that's fulfillment the other side of
happiness is excitement you're happy
when you feel like you're doing
something new you're happy when you get
to try something new you get to have fun
you get to do something that hasn't been
done before you're you're you're going
out of your comfort zone or you're
you're having this quick hit right I
mean it could be anything from I'm
excited to have my coffee yeah I'm
excited to have my Starbucks you know
when we go once a week to film we get a
Starbucks put some cream in and I'm
excited for the taste right you could be
excited for that donor that meal you
know it may not even be good for you the
Donut's not good for you but you're
still excited to have it because it
tastes so good you're chasing this
little momentary high or you could be
excited to go on that vacation you're
excited just something new this it's a
it's a moment in time
it's the little it's the candy it's the
sweets right and it's the sweets of life
it's not sustainable but it's not
designed to be sustainable
it's these little moments in time that
make us happy and that's true too but
that's why it's excitement
jumping from an airplane you know it's
exciting
it's not sustainable you're not going to
show up every day and and fall from the
airplane all day long right and so I
think where a lot of people struggle a
lot of entrepreneurs especially is we're
chasing the excitement only you're
you're chasing what it's going to feel
like when you hit your goal when you
have a million subscribers or a million
in revenue or whatever success looks
like to you
well what we're missing is the
Fulfillment part of it there's nothing
wrong with chasing those goals there's
nothing wrong with having that caffeine
high that Sugar Rush that you know hey I
hit my goal amazing there's nothing
wrong with it but if that's all there is
you need the meal
right if that's all there is you're
never actually going to be happy because
those are just moments in time
that you're you get excited today if
that something happened and then you
might wait another month before the next
exciting thing happens we're just
Adrenaline Junkies that's what
entrepreneurs are a lot of entrepreneurs
just become Adrenaline Junkies chasing
the next High
that's not sustainable That's not
healthy and that's not ultimate
happiness
you have to pair it with the Fulfillment
when you can do both
that I'm I'm chasing these big goals
these Big Dreams or even something small
I can do right now to get excited and
pairing it with what I do matters this
is fulfilling to me this is going to
make a difference in somebody's life
that's where I think you have long-term
sustainable healthy forms of happiness
the good news is both of them you can
accomplish right now
at any point in time
you could choose to help somebody you
could choose to go serve somebody right
at any point in time it could be you
know helping those people put the
groceries in their car right they could
go go help them or take the shopping
cart and and put it away for them random
act of kindness it could be going to
somebody's YouTube comments and leaving
a nice message think about a creator
that you like to follow somebody else
that you subscribe to who maybe doesn't
have as big a following go leave a nice
message how long does it take you to do
right 18 seconds you just made a
difference in somebody's life
responding to somebody who follows you
on Instagram and saying hey thank you
for following me on Instagram I really
appreciate you that's how I built my
Instagram following I'd be sitting here
at a Costco
individually messaging people who
followed me to say hey Rick hey Susan
hey Jennifer thank you so much for
following me I really appreciate you
thank you send next right seven seconds
eight seconds 15 seconds at a time
you can choose at any point to be happy
I think you're a tree and I wrote about
this in in my book built to serve I
think you're a tree what does a tree do
a tree Breeze in the carbon dioxide
which
too much of for humans is poison we
breathe the trees will breathe it in
they'll eat it they'll grow from it and
it'll spit out oxygen positivity for the
world I see that as part of our role as
leaders and as entrepreneurs is to eat
other people's negativity grow from it
get better from it and then spit out
more positivity more oxygen for the
world ultimately the people who are
negative in your life you have an
ability to influence them you have an
ability to help them see the positive
Road not through your
advice but through your actions by you
going off and doing your thing will
inspire other people to want to change
their life as well whoever is more
confident wins and when you're around
really negative people if you are
doubting your positivity they're gonna
win they're going to drag you down
But ultimately the goal is to get so
positive so optimistic so
so happy that you pull them up
that you're more positive you're more
certain in your positivity than they are
certain in their negativity and you pull
them towards making a better life
decision I have a list of beliefs that I
read every morning every single morning
I have it written on my computer I pop
it up and these are the list of beliefs
and values that I want to remind myself
of that I want to live today and every
day and I find that reminding myself of
it in the morning helps make sure that I
actually follow through on it during the
day and so one of those things that I
read to myself every morning is that
work is play one of the beliefs that I
want to espouse on a daily basis is that
work is play that work isn't just work
that work isn't a place to go and die
work isn't a place to go and struggle
and yes work is a lot of hard work right
work is a lot of a grind work is a lot
of getting stuff done and checking a lot
of things off the list right you want to
be productive and feel like you're
creating meaningful value in the world
today but it doesn't have to suck like
work can be fun and it's it's partly
enjoying the work having passion for
what you're doing right doing something
that you feel is Meaningful but also
just having fun with it and so if I look
at some of the things that I do you know
in our office environment I had Alex and
Lily over and they started breaking out
into a song
and in the morning when I'm making
videos from my my book you'll see me on
Snapchat with you know rabbit ears or
raccoon ears or some fun filter on it
and fun is different to each person
right I'm not the guy who's going to be
out cracking jokes that's maybe more
Alex's style but the point is that
you're doing the things that you can
express your creativity through that you
are having fun with if you are on your
way to your office whether your office
is your basement or your home office or
Nashville Office where you have your
employees and team members if you're on
your way to go and do work
and you are dreading it like oh another
day and it's like it feels like the
world is beating you down you're not
going to create great work like if you
feel like you have to just plow through
a whole bunch of crap every day
it's not gonna feel fun you're not going
to create an amazing experience and so
if you can approach it with how can I
have fun today it's just asking that
question how can I make this fun it's
not by taking breaks right it's not by
doing something in between to break up
the crap right it's not okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna grind through this for two
hours and then I'm gonna I'm gonna take
a celebration and go grab a coffee and
then come back and I'm going to grind
some more it's like how can you make the
grind fun
how can you inject fun into the actual
process so that you are enjoying the
process because if you can get to that
point it's not that every single minute
of every day is going to be amazing but
if you get to that point where work is
play where work is fun you're not just
going to have more fun but it's going to
show in the result as well it's going to
show in what you create you're going to
create better things it's going to add
more value it's going to help you grow
your business much more than if you go
to work every day feeling like the world
is crushing you down entrepreneurship is
one of the hardest things that you're
ever going to do in your life
and it's totally worth it
it's totally worth it whether it
actually works out or not most
entrepreneurs will fail something like
85 percent of businesses fail in the
first five years most businesses won't
work but it's totally worth it why
because you're showing yourself that you
bet on yourself you're showing yourself
that you're following through and taking
action on your ideas that you're worthy
you're showing yourself that you're
worthy
you're showing yourself that you believe
in you and if you keep doing that
you're gonna win
the path to living a happy life a
fulfilled life a life that you're proud
of
is one where you continue to show up for
yourself and the minute that you stop
when you stop showing up for yourself
when you just throw in the towel and say
this is over I'm just gonna work for
somebody else I'm gonna help somebody
else build their dreams instead of
chasing down mine that's when life
starts to fall apart you know that's the
path down
to unhappiness and depression and it
doesn't mean that everybody has to be an
entrepreneur
but what you have to do is continue to
bet on yourself you have to continue to
bet on your ideas you have to continue
to say I came up with this good idea and
because I came up with it therefore it's
a worthy Endeavor for me to chase it
down
I got asked on my live stream yesterday
how do I know when to quit you know it
is quitting is quitting bad do I quit on
something how do I know when to quit
some people say never give up never give
up always keep going and some people are
the Opposites what's the right advice
the right answer is if you love it you
have to keep going
[Music]
if you love it you have you have to find
a way to keep going
so for a lot of cases that's what
entrepreneurship is you've got a dream
you got a mission you've got some goals
that that you generally love that you
really want to to build to create to
serve to help people with
and it's that love that's gonna keep you
going because in the early days it's
gonna suck it's the it's the chewing
glass and eating to the abyss right you
have that moment of high at the
beginning of I'm gonna start this thing
oh my God this is so exciting and then
you you land into the valley of no
momentum nothing working not no results
nobody praising you anymore nobody's
celebrating you for starting the
business now you're in the actual
running of it and you're not getting the
results that you want and you're trying
to
show how you're winning and post it on
Instagram and you're but you're not and
you know you're not and you feel like a
fraud and this is this is the life cycle
that a lot of entrepreneurs go through
but if you love it you have to keep
going you have to you have to
do
you could be a lot more honest you could
be a lot more vulnerable you could be a
lot more authentic you can understand
that you have you don't have to do this
all by yourself this is my biggest
problem when I started my company I was
I was failing I was flat out failing I
was 300 bucks a month like
failing and I was too embarrassed and
ashamed to tell my friends that I was
feeling I wanted to look like I was
doing well because I turned down the
jobs that they all went and got and
they're all making high five figure
below six-figure jobs at a university
and I'm making 300 bucks a month I was
just embarrassed I was just too
embarrassed and I made it harder on
myself
to be alone you don't have to be alone
you can make it easier by just letting
people in
when you're down in the dumps being by
yourself is usually the worst thing
if you can be around other people
especially people to support you a lot
of people will
Circle back to
the idea that if you don't love it
you're going to regret it why why do you
have to keep going like why do you have
to keep going why is it so important if
you love it because you will regret it
because you will look back on this
moment in your life and say I should
have done more I could have done more I
regret not giving it one more week one
more month one more year I regret it you
will regret it that's the only thing
that saved my first business
I quit on my partner I told him I'm done
I need to feel like I'm a valuable human
again nothing I'm doing is working and I
hate how this makes me feel as a person
nothing against you or the business just
how I feel I need to feel like I'm
valuable again somehow
that was the conversation and then the
next day I woke up and I said I can't
quit because I'm going to regret this I
know I'm gonna regret this I'm going to
be an old man at 40.
41 now I'm getting old man at 40 and
regret that I wasted my life and I
didn't do this thing
and that's the only thing that gave me
the the courage
the motivation the energy to get back up
and just keep going you will regret this
if you love it and you stop now you will
regret this for your entire life
now on the flip side I think there are
many things that you should quit on
sooner
the the difference is if you don't love
it you need to quit on it if you don't
love it anymore and maybe you never
loved it in the first place then you
need to move on because you will never
win doing work that you hate
the people who are at the top of their
game people have I've studied how many
successful people have I studied in
profiled and showcased on on all of
these channels how many so many people
right the one thing they all have in
common is that they love what they do
they love the process they love the work
they love the grind it's not a grind for
them because they're they're in it so
much and they love it
so that's who you're going up against
right and if you don't love it you're
always going to lose no matter how smart
you are you're gonna lose because you're
going up against people who absolutely
love the thing and so that's what you
need you need to be loving your thing
and so if you're in it just as a
strategy You're Gonna Lose move on
immediately as soon as your heart's not
into it either sell it or if it's too
new then then you just flat out move on
I think people say in relationships are
too long I think people stay in
businesses for too long because you're
afraid of failure because you're afraid
of what it means if you quit on
something and go to something else
you're afraid of what people are gonna
say you're afraid of what the person
looking back at you in the mirror is
going to think if you quit you're afraid
of the uncertainty of where to go next
because if this thing at least I know
what this thing is doing I don't know
what the future holds to me if I go
somewhere else
a lot of people are handcuffed by having
a little bit of money not not a lot but
enough to survive and that then prevents
them from taking the next jump which
they actually need to do because their
heart's not in the thing so many people
start a business because they're just
trying to make money
people ask you what's what's the number
one business to get into for this year
to make a lot of money that's to run
question you're asking that question
you're gonna lose you can't start with
how to make money you start with the
thing that you love that brings value
and inside of that you're making money
making money is important a hundred
percent if you don't make money you will
not have a business making money has to
be in your top five of priorities but if
you make it Number One You're Gonna Lose
because you're always gonna be chasing
the next hot thing never get good enough
at anything to actually be the best in
the world which is actually how you
start to make a lot of money you need to
be the best in best in the world or
something how do you get that by loving
the thing so much
and by wanting to serve and help people
get better at it too
that's how you win the language you use
about yourself when you're by yourself
is what will make or break
your self-esteem
when we talk to other people when we
post on Instagram when we share our
lives we always wanted to to look good
and be amazing and be so positive right
most people's Instagram stories are are
just all of these amazing highlights and
how perfect life is and then you go home
when you're by yourself and you look at
yourself in the mirror and people you
know cry themselves asleep
what's the message when you talk to
yourself
what's the message when you're alone
what are you saying about yourself when
you can start to fix that self-talk that
inner dialogue that starts a shift
everything inside you to then create
amazing things outside you
I remember when I first got started
making YouTube videos my cell Talk
was uh in conflict because I had my
parents who I remembered the voice you
know there's a picture of my parents
behind me on my wall in my office and
when people ask me what's my favorite
quote of all time it's it's what my
parents used to tell me that I'm Evan
because Shirley Carmichael I could do
anything that I believe that I can
and that is a constant reminder that I
still today you know at 41 still use
still tell myself still remind myself of
like I am having a Shirley Carmichael I
could do anything that I believe that I
can
and it's helpful and valuable and what a
gift I'm so grateful for my parents for
that
when I was getting started on YouTube
though the other voice that was in my
head was
you're introverted you're shy you suck
on camera
anybody who makes videos has a big ego
just needs to be famous
and so I really struggled with that
because I had competing voices in my
head
it wasn't even what other people were
telling me to do it was me myself when
I'm by myself thinking about myself
that constant inner struggle with the
voices in my head left me struggling
left me making super slow progress let
me start it and stop it and started and
stopping if you look at my videos I
started and then I took big breaks and
then I started again and I took more big
breaks and it wasn't until I solved that
inner conflict that I started to get
more results and I started to be more uh
productive and I started to stop
stopping I started to stop stopping I
stopped for crashed today I just did it
because I wasn't so caught up in my head
and the discussion in the in the
dialogue and the voices and I just
replaced it with
better thinking about myself better
messages to myself
I think when you can do that your life
starts to change because it's not other
people's opinions that we that really
shape us it's
other people's opinions that then
influence our own self-talk that then
that's what shape us you are where you
are because of you because of the
choices you've made you are right now
here stuck where you're stuck it's not
the government's fault it's not the
economy's fault it's not the algorithm's
fault it's not your parents fault it's
not even your fault I'm not even here
talking about placing blame it's not
about who we're gonna blame it's about
taking the responsibility to fix it to
say I don't want to stay stuck here
where I am right now things have to
change this is not this is not my final
destination
I'm going places you're going places and
taking the responsibility to make that
change happen where too many people just
get stuck up on the blame like while I'm
here because well because of the economy
or because of the president or because
my parents or because of my education
because whatever circumstances and we
use that as a valid excuse a reason
for why we won't take action
well it's not your fault and because
it's not your fault
we have someone to blame and so that
means we can just stay stuck
and unfortunately that's where most
people are stuck they're stuck being
stuck they're stuck placing blame
they're stuck because it's easy because
it's easier to just shut up the world
and go dime with the Netflix and
entertain yourself as opposed to
actually fixing the problem when there
are problems that show up in life and
that's gonna happen for everybody the
most common responses people have are
one to blame somebody else because it's
not your fault and two to go dive into
entertainment
as opposed to saying I don't even care
whose fault it is but I'm going to take
responsibility for him at and I'm going
to invest in myself to flip from
entertainment to education so that
changes can start to happen because
until you break that Loop until you
break that cycle
you stay stuck and and it's comfortable
it's comfortable and it feels good to
know that it's not our fault but
ultimately you're not happy
the short term you're happy because you
can just put the blame on somebody else
but long term you're not happy you're
not happy because you never get the
growth you never get the progress you
never get your goals you never
accomplish your dreams and you're you're
stuck there knowing that you're capable
of more
I went through this very recently on my
YouTube channel so
um one of the strategies that I've been
helping some of my friends with there's
one guy in particular who has blown up
blown up on YouTube
thanks to one key strategy that I gave
him and I told this to him maybe a year
and a half ago and he started applying
it maybe six months ago and you see
Channel popping off growing faster than
I'm growing
off of my strategy and I finally came to
the realization like why am I not doing
this for my own channels I'm telling
other people to do it most people never
take action but this guy actually took
action on it and he's he's crushing me
now doing this stuff why are we not
listening to our own advice like why am
I not doing the same thing on my channel
yet
and it came down to well I'm worried
about I'm worried about my team I'm
worried about how much extra work it is
I'm worried about
um
you know mostly about my team and like
how we've done things in the past and
changing things up and I finally came to
the realization that you know things
this has to change because if it if if I
can't make this work
then it's my fault this is my fault and
my team's livelihood is my
responsibility and I need to be
constantly growing and getting better
and if YouTube's algorithm changes I
need to be on top of it and I need to be
guiding my team in the right direction
because they rely on me for their career
and for their impact now could they go
get another job of course but hopefully
they like working with me and the work
that we're doing and feel like they're
they're valued and and what they're
creating is having an impact and so me
being afraid
is not a good enough reason and so it
wasn't until I really owned that to say
this is you know this maybe took a
couple months for me for really the sink
in like my own advice is being used
for somebody to help them blow up and
we're not doing it because I'm afraid of
the impact that it's going to have on my
team and that can't be a good enough
reason that can't be a good enough
reason because ultimately I'm doing a
disservice to my team I'm doing
disservice to myself and I'm doing a
disservice to you
because the more people who can see
these videos the more
more belief we spread in the world the
more impact we have the more people's
lives change the more great companies
are built this is my mission and so if I
don't do it then it's my fault it's not
YouTube for changing it's not it's not
anybody on my team for resisting it's me
it's my fault and so when when I finally
accepted that then you can move fast
then I messaged some of the key people
on my team and said okay here's here's
what we need to start to do and I
understand there are problems with this
so let's let's fix the problems because
this has to happen
and now we're doing it and now we're
moving quickly and you know hopefully
we'll start to see the results uh but it
wasn't until I accepted the
responsibility for it to say I'm not
going to stay stuck in this rut that
we're in
that things start to change you did not
ask for this painful situation you're
going through right now you did not ask
for this health issue for this work
issue for this environmental issue you
didn't ask for this thing to happen to
you this is where we struggle because
you didn't cause this it's probably not
your fault right maybe it is your fault
but it's probably not your fault this
thing that's happened there's a lot that
happened to make this thing happen for
you right now and so it's so easy to get
stuck in the land of negativity why me
woe is me why did this happen as opposed
to flipping to say it's the best this
thing that's happened to me right now
it's the best
when I broke my neck
I was on my tour I broke my neck what I
said was it's the best
is it actually good to break my neck
probably not but it's it's my chance to
show myself what I'm capable of I
remember being woken up so I passed out
I had a a concussion I fell on the floor
I woke up like I fainted I woke up and I
remember the the hospital uh had sent uh
their their ambulance and also fire
people showed up and
my circulation was getting shut off I
couldn't feel my arms I couldn't feel my
legs they're worried that I'm having a
heart attack and I remember
going through this in my head as I'm
explaining what's going on they asked me
if I was okay and I said I feel okay
but then I came through my arm I can't
do my right arm I can't feel my legs I
can't feel and most people would be kind
of freaking out at this point oh my God
I can't feel my arm I can't feel my legs
and I'm calmly explaining that oh I
can't feel my left hand right now I
can't feel my right hand right now and
just walking them through what's going
on and in my head this is why it's so
important whether this is actually true
or not in my head what I'm telling
myself is this is the best I am the
greatest patient of all time
as people
are normally freaking out this moment
I'm calm I'm explaining what's going on
I'm I'm amazing right and I would never
say that stuff out loud but that's what
the voice is inside my head that this is
the best this is me I'm amazing let's go
let's solve this problem and what it
does is when you're in that negative
situation it switches you to a place of
possibility if you are stuck in
complaining and why everything is so bad
and why this happened to me all you're
doing is perpetuating the negative
situation you're not actually solving
anything when you can flip it to say
this is the best
this is my chance to learn to grow to
improve to solve this to show myself
what I'm capable of what it does is it
puts you in a place of resourcefulness
it takes you from a place of
helplessness into one of resourcefulness
that then allows you to go up and solve
the problem
that immediate thing that nobody asked
for that you would never wish upon your
worst enemy that's happened to you right
now it gives you the tools to actually
come out of it and so switching your
mindset telling yourself that it's the
best when you've got these moments of
pain and struggle and suffering where
you just want to blame the world and
complain and tell everybody how negative
it is you flip it
it's
three words maybe you're facing that
situation right now maybe you're doing
something you hate right now or
something if if it's not right now
listen I promise you something is coming
at some point that negativity is coming
for you
and so use that as inspiration it's the
best what do I do with my life
one of the most important questions that
I get asked over and over and over and
over again people are struggling with
what do I do with my life you see your
parents doing something you see your
friends doing something you know that
that's not the life that you want but
you're afraid of actually chasing down
your dreams you see people living their
life on Instagram and it's so beautiful
and perfect
and you're worried that you're not going
to measure up that you're not going to
live up to it that if you try and do
your thing
you're going to fail
and so you're constantly stuck in this
what do I do with my life pull between
the safe life that everybody around you
is living and they want you to live for
yourself or the dream life that you know
you're capable of but you don't know
quite what it looks like what do I do
with my life
here's what I found you're gonna have
moments in your life where you have
absolute clarity
and equally you'll have moments in your
life where you have zero clue what to do
let's break those two down when you have
absolute Clarity when you know exactly
what you want to do when it feels right
when you have momentum the best thing
you can do is put your blinders on and
go to work the best thing you can do is
shut down everything else and get to
work building your dream
we often hedge we often play small we
often don't put as much in because we're
afraid but when you have those moments
of clarity you have to go play a bigger
game you have to start betting on
yourself right now I look at my YouTube
channels as an example
this is a pretty special moment in time
and things are very well aligned for me
right now I mean been doing YouTube for
12 years built up a lot of traction have
a lot of momentum been helping a lot of
my friends made a lot of new friends as
a result of the channel got into rooms
that otherwise I shouldn't be in because
of the success of my channels and it's
been a lot of work and the early years
did not pay off very well at all I share
on my Instagram a lot of my traction and
you know first five years of the channel
we didn't even have 10 000 subscribers
in the first five years and then we went
and hit you know next five years two
million subscribers now passing three
million subscribers on the main Channel
but a lot of a lot of slow slow growth
but right now is a very special moment
in time right now I need to push harder
on the YouTube channels right now we've
launched I don't know how many channels
a lot of channels we got a dozen
channels plus maybe at this point I need
to be pushing more on YouTube this is a
moment in time this is the window here
is so wide open that I need to jump
through it because at some point it will
close and and I don't want to look back
on this moment say I wish I pushed
harder I wish I wasn't afraid I wish I I
did the thing that I knew was right and
we'll have it you'll have those moments
too in your life where you just see it
so clearly you you have this Vision you
you see it all working out but you're
afraid to go actually take the action
you're afraid to go all in on it you're
afraid to do what is necessary and then
what ends up happening is regret because
you'll be at the end of your life or
even 10 years later thinking
I knew it I saw it so clearly there was
this opportunity in front of me and I
wanted to do and I love to do it but I
was too afraid and somebody went else
somebody else went off and made millions
of dollars off of my idea does that ever
happen to you somebody made Millions off
of my idea
no they just went and took action when
you were sitting being afraid and so
when you have those moments of clarity
you have to push everything else aside
and go after that thing
even though it's scary even though it's
too big even though it feels Beyond you
you have to go after that thing because
that's where your Genius lies
and you either lean into your Genius and
go change the world
or you live the rest of your life with
regret you have to force it where are
you stuck right now is it your business
is it your relationships is it your
career is it where is it your mindset
your health habits like where do you
feel is the number one place that you're
stuck right now in your life where are
you stuck get really clear on that
because having that honest conversation
with yourself really matters that's how
you can start to make the change and the
point of this is not to say that you
suck and look at the the disaster you
made for yourself and I can't believe
you're not doing better this is not a
negative self-top exercise this is a
we're going to have an honest evaluation
of where we are right now this is you
sitting down with you you can look in
the mirror you can Journal you can go
for a walk whatever you need to do to
have that conversation with yourself but
figure out what is the number one area
that you feel stuck right now that you
don't want to be stuck in anymore that
if you're still stuck in the same spot
that you are in right now one year from
today you're gonna be upset you're going
to be upset that you missed an
opportunity that you've wasted another
year of your life so so where is that
number one area that you feel stuck
right now get some clarity on it maybe
it comes right away maybe you gotta
digest it but get some clarity on that
because that that's a starting point to
making some changes the fact that you
look at your calendar today tomorrow
next week and nothing excites you okay
great what can you shift and it may
require wholesale change it may require
you doing some drastic thing but more
likely you could probably just do one
small shift like just start building
momentum just start doing one little
thing every day
to start to train yourself to start to
just push the ball a little bit forward
because often we think we have to make
some giant change and the only answer is
to move to Mexico and then it never
happens because to move to Mexico takes
you however many you know months and
budget and all the stuff you get stuck
in plannable instead of doing
what's a small step what's a small tweak
that you can make to today's calendar to
inject more energy into it with
something that you're going to love
doing that will give you more energy
that then now you have energy for other
things as well right some kind of
immediate momentum you can't be doing
the stop that you hate
you have to find a way out it may not be
today it may not be right now it may not
be this week but you have to find a way
out
so if you're working for a boss that you
hate
long term you can't be doing that
anymore if you're in a business that you
hate and maybe you started the business
and you hate it long term you can't be
doing that anymore you will never win
doing work that you hate
people say well you have to do whatever
it takes but you won't you won't do
whatever it takes if you don't like the
thing and you're going up against people
you're competing against people who love
the thing they love it and for you it's
just a strategy and so the key is you
have to leave the things that you don't
love doing and leaning on the things
that you do and find a way to use the
thing that you love to then bring value
to other people so you can have real
business so you can go make an impact
you can build the life that that you
deserve that your family deserves and
the people around you deserve as well so
if you don't love it
and worse if you hate it you have to
find a way out and that may not be today
this is where people get cut up and the
struggles like well I don't I don't like
it but I have no other plan okay well we
have to start working towards it so that
a year from today you're not in the same
spot but today you have to go show up
and kick butt on the thing that is
causing all of these problems for you so
I look at my YouTube channels for
example we've done over 10 000 videos
just crossed three million subscribers
on the main Channel thank you guys
appreciate you
I've been doing this for 12 years April
how how do I keep going how do I keep
making videos how do we how do we crank
out 10 000 videos plus and how have I
not burnt out how have we not taken time
off
because I love it
doesn't work for me because I look
forward to this because I look at my
filming day which is the Tuesday when I
make these videos and I'm excited to
make more content to share with you guys
to hopefully maybe this today is the
video that finally sinks in for somebody
for somebody watching this video whether
it's true or not the message I tell
myself is somebody is going to watch
this video right here today this one and
it's gonna be the light bulb moment for
them not everybody but for one person
that that video this one right now is
going to be the light bulb moment for
them that gives them the big unlock and
so I have to show up I want to show up
I'm excited to show up I can't wait to
show up
12 years keep making content and and as
long as I love it I'm gonna keep doing
it and so this is why if you're trying
to do YouTube just as a strategy you're
going up against people who love the
thing
so you're always going to lose meanwhile
there's something that you love doing
and that's where you need to be long
term who are the people who've done this
thing
who are the people who are great at this
thing who are the people who you look up
to respect admire maybe they're physical
people humans that you can touch and and
have coffee with and have a phone call
and go meet uh and are in your life or
maybe the people you've never met yet
and and you can learn from them on
YouTube on Instagram on podcasts but who
are the people that are doing this thing
they're great at it the thing that
you're struggling with right now they're
world class at it
and you want to try to find some time to
be around them more
you make it part of your daily ritual
now to be around them more if it's
somebody who's in your circle you're
trying to have a regular call with them
that may be a daily call for a while
maybe it's a weekly call maybe it's a
monthly coffee but you're trying to
spend more time with them and then you
supplement with with regular content you
start following the people on YouTube
who make you feel more of that who make
you want to play a bigger game you start
following people on Instagram who lift
you up who make you feel the hope and
possibility with conscious intent you're
picking who you're surrounding yourself
with and who you let into your life
based off of goal number one
so goal number one is to have more
belief in yourself and the biggest
problem you have is you don't have
enough belief in yourself great you can
definitely supplement with a lot of my
content I mean at least that's the
intent with every video I make I'm
trying to inject more belief into people
and to myself as well as other people if
your number one goal from Step number
one is you want to
uh have better health great who are the
channels that you need to subscribe to
to make you feel if you're watching
people who are constantly living healthy
who are working out who are doing the
right diet who are taking care of
themselves who value themselves if
you're constantly around that
they will lift you up they will make you
more healthy not just because of the
strategies the strategies alone aren't
aren't much it's the it's the
environment it's the mindset it's the
belief by being around these people they
automatically pull you up they
automatically make you feel like it's
possible they automatically become a
part of your daily and they push you
towards Having the courage to do the
thing that you want to do have a
reminder system in your life constantly
what are the things because you're
feeling it right now hopefully if you're
watching you're feeling it right now
you're feeling excited right now you're
gonna make a change right now and then
tomorrow you're going to fall back to
who you used to be so what what do you
need in your environment what do you
need in your habits and your daily
routines to remind you you need to
remind your system so it can become more
automatic that it doesn't rely on your
self-will and your discipline constantly
that it gets introduced to you
constantly whether that's
uh YouTube videos why hey espresso five
days a week every morning hey I'm here
let's go here's a new video for you uh
if it's Ed mylett's Channel or Tony
Robbins Channel or or Oprah Winfrey's
videos like whoever or if it's books or
podcasts if it's your physical
environment if it's uh morning intention
like just figure it out for yourself
and schedule it in
schedule in the reminders
scheduling the intentionality so that
this doesn't just become a one-off
moment but that it's a daily reminder
it's a daily consistency it's daily
momentum because you need that you make
that change happen you do those three
things
you you do the audit on your life you
take immediate action and you schedule
in that consistency
[Music]
your life changes
and then the concept of swimming forever
or beyond the mountain is more Mountains
doesn't feel overwhelming doesn't feel
scary doesn't feel impossible it's
invigorating
it's amazing
it's awesome
because you're on a mission
if you've got a vision for a better
world and for a better you
and now you're actually going to show up
and make that happen I don't know what
to do next all I know is I don't want to
be doing what I'm doing right now
did that happen to you you know that you
don't like your current life you know
that you don't like your current habits
you know that you don't like your
current schedule your routine what
you're doing who you're hanging with you
know you don't like any of that stuff
but you don't know what to do to change
it does that happen
if that's you right now
then your immediate goal
is the exact opposite it's not to go all
in on one thing is to try many things to
give yourself a lot of exposure to say
yes to as many things as possible that
are inside your code of ethics right
don't go
steal something from a store because
it's something new
right that are inside your code of
ethics to taste a test to try to explore
to find the thing that might be the next
thing for you
and to lower the barrier
for just getting started so I went
through this
in my website when I have my website a
lot of people don't know me from my
website because if you go to my website
now there's not that much there but I
used to have a hundred thousand plus
pages of content on my website and I was
playing the SEO game and Publishing tons
of content and and we had a lot of the
big name people uh in entrepreneurship
creating content for our website and I
was selling ads off the site
and I realized at the beginning
I was all in at the beginning I loved it
I wanted to write I wanted to bring on
people I wanted to we had 5 000 people
or so writing for the website I loved
that it was all then I saw this moment
in time I was going for it and we
quickly grew the website but I found
that as maybe year three year four I was
starting to lose interest
wasn't excited anymore
and I didn't know what else to do inside
the website to bring that energy back
so I started to taste test explore other
things outside the website and one of
those experiments was YouTube
one of those tests was me starting my
first YouTube channel
and I really sucked at it
I can watch my old videos it took me a
long time to get half decent in front of
the camera I sucked at it
I had no natural inclination for it I
told myself well I'm I'm an introvert
and I'm shy so I'm always going to suck
on camera
[Music]
but I realized I don't know I just I
liked it
I liked it I like doing it I liked
making visual content instead of written
content because I'm a visual learner I
like the idea that
maybe there's somebody else out there
who'll watch my video and be inspired by
it and that maybe makes a shift for them
I never expected to be YouTube famous
because at the time YouTube famous
wasn't a thing nobody was YouTube famous
especially in education nobody was
making long-form educational videos it
just didn't exist and so I thought you
know what I'll just keep doing it
because I love it that if 50 people 100
people watch this video that's 1500
people who watch the video that's maybe
a couple lives changed because of me
being courageous enough at the time to
press record and make a video
and so that kept me that kept me going
and eventually I turned it into
something that then I shut down my
website and it went all in on YouTube
and so when you don't know what to do
you need to get out of your typical
routine go for a walk go to go go drive
somewhere you've never been before take
an extra long shower like do the things
that help get you create creative ideas
and then whatever comes
whether it's start a YouTube channel
start a podcast start writing the book
start singing a song Start like whatever
ideas come to you they will probably
sound crazy
for someone like me it would be crazy to
have a YouTube channel
[Music]
or someone who doesn't like being in
front of the camera who doesn't like
seeing himself who who thought that
people who filmed themselves had to have
a huge ego and be chasing Fame and I
didn't want that
for someone like that I would have never
said never never that I would have
a hundred thousand subscribers you know
let alone 3 million plus never I would
have never thought that was possible
your brain does not want you to hit your
dreams your brain
is designed to keep you small to keep
you safe to keep you protected your
heart wants to create amazing things
your heart has Big Dreams your heart
sees a beautiful world and says I want
to go make something better and then you
wake up the next day and your brain
takes over and says you can't do that
that's too risky that's too dangerous
stay small stay safe you didn't go to
school for that and what ends up
happening is this constant back and
forth between your heart and your brain
when you're getting these motivated
moments when you want to do amazing
things and then your brain takes over
again and keeps you small and this is
the path that so many entrepreneurs go
on this roller coaster ride of up and
down and up and down and up and down and
up and down
sound familiar
it's time to get off the roller coaster
and start making progress on your dreams
today's video I'm going to show you how
so yesterday I got asked on my live
stream Evan what's the most important
part of your daily routine
and so many people have so many
different daily routines and it's easy
to do the things like drink a glass of
water in the morning go outside and get
some sunlight and you know all of these
things but the most important thing for
me is actually having my intention for
the day I've actually been experimenting
with writing it out the day before so
this is this is what I wrote last night
of basically my entire schedule
and then more than just what I'm gonna
do more than just what I'm gonna do it's
how I wanna feel what's my intention
going into it so if I look at this I'm
supposed to be recording and special
videos right now right that was on my
list 10 30 a.m record and special videos
it's right there and here get a head
start even though you don't want to
recording videos at the beginning is
always difficult for me there's a couple
reasons why I'm I'm shy I'm introverted
I don't crave the spotlight I don't like
being in front of the camera
I don't I don't I don't do it for ego
purposes
and also I'm afraid I'm afraid
because I want it to be great I want
this video to be the next best video I
don't want to disappoint people my
number one fear is going to be that I'll
disappoint somebody and so every time
you make something you risk
disappointing somebody where it's easier
just to stay small stay safe don't make
anything today and so it's on my list
the to do right I think a lot of you if
you're watching this video you probably
have a list of to-do's but how many of
you are actually doing the things on
your list of to-do's the hardest part
off is just getting started already as I
started recording this video it's a lot
easier to keep going and recording more
videos this is the first one that I'm
recording today and so having that
written down get a head start even
though you don't want to
reminds me of who I want to be
and what I find so valuable about this
is I write this the night before
so the night before you know it's it's
11 o'clock at night I usually sit on the
floor and I review my calendar for the
next day and I write out what I'm going
to be doing and I've added how do I want
to feel what's my reminder to myself
before stepping into that task imagine
you're being your own high performance
coach sitting there telling yourself how
you want to feel remember your intention
before starting that next task
and I knew
Okay evan this is what you always do
before you make a video there's a little
bit of procrastinations a little bit of
fear there's a little bit of slowness
there's a little bit of not laziness but
there's a little bit of just
apprehension before you get started why
because you don't want to start because
you're afraid because you don't want to
you don't want to support people so I
write down that message again get a head
start even though you don't want to
look at your life and you enjoy what
you're doing
people ask me do I burn out in what I'm
doing like I don't I don't I don't burn
out I like I like it too much like this
making these videos I'm gonna go home
after this and make more videos probably
but this video that I'm making for you
right now is not draining or depleting
of my energy it's contributing to my
energy I am manufacturing energy by
doing this
so that's why it's easy to do 10 000
more videos
because it gives me more than I give to
it
I get more energy as a result of doing
this I'm going to be a better
entrepreneur better husband a better
father a better boss a better teammate a
better Mentor as a result of making this
video
it gives me energy look at your work
that's how you avoid burnout if I was
doing things that that sap manage if I
was in charge of like washing these cars
I'd be burnt out in in five hours I
would hate my life because I don't enjoy
washing cars I don't enjoy cars really
so look at your schedule do a nice audit
on your life how many of the activities
that you're doing every day are giving
you energy versus taking away energy how
many of the people that you're spending
time with are giving you energy versus
taking away energy
and you need to start shifting from I'm
just gonna chase an opportunity I'm
going to do whatever it takes you won't
you won't do whatever it takes
not if you don't like it but if you
don't love it you won't do whatever it
takes
because you don't love it and that's
okay stop judging yourself for not
working hard enough just you're not lazy
something you don't want to work hard
you just don't like the thing that
you're doing
this doesn't feel like work to me
so it's getting honest with yourself
it's doing an audit it's looking at your
calendar are you generally excited about
the things you're about to do today and
tomorrow and if not then then we have to
start to shift out of them
right do the things that give you energy
instead of taken away
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there I want to teach myself that if my
heart's beaten but it's a sign that I
need to go do the thing most of the
things that we're afraid of doing are
because of other people's opinions
you're playing small because you're
worried how somebody's going to judge
you you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street